Motivation has gotten you through every win, loss, good day and bad.
So, as you approach your big moment, breathe in the wins.
Breathe out the losses.
You will fall short of your goals,...
...and you will get frustrated,...
...but those are the moments where you must use the past to keep yourself looking forward.
Take what you can use from the negative experience...
...then quickly recall the last time this happened and how you pushed through.
Use your own history of perseverance as motivation.
Never let your missteps have power over you.
Each time you fall short of your goals, learn from it,...
...and let it go so you can return focus to the thrill of accomplishing your goal.
Each time you succeed, listen to your favorite playlist.
Connect the music to the feeling of success.
Every time you hear it, it will remind you of that feeling...
...and push you even harder.
With every accomplishment, stop and relish the moment,...
...so you can relive it the next time you are faced with the same challenge.
Skill can get you the win, but your motivational methods get you to an elite level.
To keep winning, you have to keep going.
To keep going, you have to keep pushing,...
...and to keep pushing, you have to be able to lock in your motivation anytime, anywhere.
Let go of your losses.
Recall your wins.
Once you master that skill, you will always be a step ahead as you chase your dream.